- You're a very successful
business woman now.
So, your path was very unusual.
So, how did this all start?
- Well, you know,
I grew up in a world where
women are less than, right?
I think the easiest way to
explain it is that from the time
a child is old enough to speak
until the day that they die,
if you are a male, if you are
a boy, as you become a man,
your entire life, you say, when
you wake up in the morning,
you say, thank you God for giving me life.
And then you say, thank you
God for not making me a woman.
- What?
- Thank you, God, for
not making me a woman.
- Like literally they say that like?
- Every day, from the day
they're old enough to speak.
You see your son saying it,
you watch your husband
saying it, your father.
- How that must impact you
as a woman in that community?
Wow, that's tough.
Um, and wow,
and you said your daughter
changed your life, right?
- My daughter, Miriam,
is the reason I'm alive.
I mean, that's just the fact.
- You said your daughter
changed your life as well.
- Absolutely, she was born.
I had to change me,
to, to fit my daughter.
- So well, speaking back of your daughter,
was there one moment
that kind of stuck out.
- And I want her to be like y'all
- Oh!
- She's watching y'all,
she's watching you.
- And we, we want.
- She's watching y'all.
- I know, and we also want you
to be whoever you are deep in there.
- That's the main thing.
- Yeah that's, yeah that's
it be whoever you want to be.
So, what did your daughters say?
- So my daughters, really
the beginning of my story
and the person who helped me leave,
because it was an eight year trajectory.
And it started when
Miriam was five years old,
I have a daughter named Miriam.
She was asking, well, I
would like to play ball.
I want to, I want to play basketball.
I want to do this.
I want to learn how to sing
and I want to play the guitar.
And she was constantly said,
no, you can't dance in public
because a man might see
you and have bad thoughts.
You can't sing in public
because a man might see
you and have bad thoughts.
And my little five-year-old
turned to my husband
and she would say, but why
isn't that his responsibility?
My five-year-old.
- Out of the mouth of babies, yeah.
- And then for the first
time she gave me permission,
because my entire life,
I thought I was bad.
That it wasn't okay for me,
but you couldn't convince me
that my five-year-old was bad.
And she was saying,
this doesn't make sense.
Why can't men control themselves?
And by the way, thank you.
Excuse me.
(audience applause)
- And by the way, they can.
- And they should.
- Yes, they can, they can.
- And so that was when I
started educating myself.
It took me eight years
before I walked out the door.
If I had stayed,
she would have been
married off at 18 or 19,
like everyone else.
- Yeah.
- She certainly wouldn't be in college.
She certainly wouldn't be a tech genius.
- Well, she changed your
life and you changed hers.
That's amazing.
- I mean, we literally saved
each other, and you know?
- Wow.
Okay, so what's your favorite
thing to do um, now that,
You know, now that you would
have been forbidden to
do something before,
like what's your favorite thing to do?
- Dance.
- Oh!
- I do love to dance.
I do love to dance.
- I love dancing.
- Yeah I love dancing.
- Yes.
- And so to be able to actually move,
to just let go and dance
is something I really love.
- I love that.